in today's morning rounds for the first
time in the US doctors have brought a
heart back to life and successfully
transplanted transplanted it into
another person they used a special
device to revive the heart of a 26 year
old donor who died of cardiac arrest
the doctors say the recipient a military
veteran is doing well the device called
an organ care system or heart in a box
looks like this it's currently in
clinical trials including that
breakthrough surgery dr. tara Narula is
cardiologist at Lenox Hill Hospital
northwell health in new york tara good
morning good morning how did they pull
this off teri you look at that new guy
yep you know it's been 52 years 1967 was
the first heart transplant and we've
really been doing them the same way this
traditional way and this really has the
potential to kind of revolutionize how
we transplant patients and so
essentially in the traditional heart
transplant somebody the donor is brain
dead right so they have no brain
function but their heart is working
really well it's pumping normally so the
transplant team goes in they take the
heart out and immediately put it in a
cooler the heart's not beating in the
cooler but they only have six hours
essentially to get it to the recipient
and implant it shock it back to life
with this new technique you're
essentially allowing someone to die
their heart function to stop so you take
the breathing to about you pronounce
them dead and at that point you take the
heart out but you immediately put it
into that heart box as you saw where
it's brought back to life it's perfused
with warm blood and nutrients and oxygen
and so it's kind of almost like a normal
physiologic state the heart is beating
and that buys the surgeons about 12
hours to get the heart to the new
recipient how did they even know that
this was possible this has been done
outside of this country for the past
several years in the UK and in Australia
they've done over a hundred cases and
they found when they followed these
patients over the last couple years that
they seemed to do just as well in terms
of survival and the heart function as
those patients who have the traditional
heart transplant so what does this mean
for the thousands of people who are
waiting for a heart transplant
well this is really good news I mean
exactly so it can imagine waiting for
months and waiting in
and then potentially never getting a
heart many people passed away while
they're waiting and so the the surgeon
who performed this yesterday said this
has the potential to increase the donor
pool by about 30% 30% this is a big
number you have any word on the
patient's prognosis who got the heart so
we heard this morning he's up he's
walking around he's doing well he's 60
year old military veteran who had had
really end-stage heart failure but the
doctors the team really wanted to tell
everyone that we also have to thank the
donor I mean to make for the families to
make this tough decision at a time when
they're grieving
you know this donor he was 26 years old
he had taken care of disabled
individuals during his life and now in
death he saved five more individuals by
donating six organs deke is that
transportation progress with the process
which you say now was initially with six
hours and now they can have 12 right so
that's really a game-changer right so
for example if they're in trinny hearts
per year go unused because they can't
make that travel distance to the
mainland so this really opens the door
to the number of people you would be
able to give hearts to that may have
gone unused it can come from much
farther from farther away exactly 60
year-old man now has a heart of a 26
year-old yes edible we live an amazing
time thank you very much